[Music]
what are the differences between the two
types of neck results seen in the mcu
which one is the real deal or are they
both the same just wielded differently
by the two users that is gaul the god
butcher and heller the goddess of death
so let us explain to you guys what they
really are let's get down with it
let's take a look at the necro thoughts
wielded by heller firstly these obsidian
swords known as the neck resorts used by
her at a time of asgards expanding over
the nine realms were really powerful
weapons the neck resorts can easily
dispatch and slay the majority of beings
including elite as guardians like the
warriors three and even stronger
characters like thor can withstand a
necros but only for a certain degree
they can still hurt him pierce his skin
blind him and even kill him if they
impaled him in the right places
these neck resorts are based on an
amalgamation of two different weapons
from the comics the knight sword which
is hella's cursed sword and that she was
able to summon at any time and the
all-black the necrosol which was the
first symbiote who manifested his form
from null into a powerful sword with
dark properties while not stated
anywhere that they were in some way
related to the all black the power that
heller had with these weapons and their
name does bring about a big question
mark maybe they were portions of the all
black trap in nilfheim which was also a
place of darkness and lifelessness
so anyway let's take a look at the other
neck resort the one that was seen in the
latest movie thor love and thunder this
sword just like in the comics was found
by the antagonist gore when he escaped
from near death in the desert in the
comics the sword was found beside two
gods that were dead one black and the
other golden in color whereas in the
movie the only dead god was the one that
was all black in color and a golden god
named rafu was alive and well however
the necrosote did beckon to gore and he
gladly accepted it and slayed rapu for
basically being a [ __ ]
in his interplanetary campaign against
all girls gore used the neck resort but
it also eventually corrupted him and
bound his life energy to it the
all-black neck resort was a powerful
weapon that could slay gods at will it
gave the user immense superhuman
abilities and gave them the ability to
use shadows to transport to other places
and realms instantaneously the weapon
also had the ability to summon shadow
monsters to aid its owner's nefarious
plans it infects its wielder with an
unknown type of virus that slowly kills
its hosts the virus could pretty well be
the constituted matter of the all black
that was also used to create the
symbiotes segor could very well have had
the symbiote material inside him
so what are the similarities and
differences between these two neck
resorts both these two weapons can kill
gods and powerful beings both of them
are black and are associated with evil
and darkness and yes neither of their
origins have been explained properly but
what about their differences well the
ones used by heller are of a different
design while gaur's weapon was a classic
double-edged blade with a pretty neat
handle while hella's weapons could
summon other blades and weapons the one
wielded by gore could summon shadow
creatures which might as well be the
mcu's versions of symbiotes as they did
resemble the amorphous shape-shifting
beings that were related to venom maybe
they were a proto-form of the symbiotes
proto-symbiotes one more thing gore's
weapon can speak directly to the user
corrupt his mind and slowly turn him to
the dark side
so conclusion although not stated
directly the necrosod of gore was indeed
the all black it had all the properties
and powers that
were canon to that weapon it was a black
weapon found in the desert beside a dead
god which was all black in color as well
similar to the canon storyline of the
comics it could kill and slay all types
of gods and even celestials as we could
see two celestials hiding in the
omnipotent city it was evil and can
corrupt the mind of the users and can
summon shadow creatures from the
darkness which resembles protoforms of
symbiotes so yeah pretty much the
all-black necrosort and as for the ones
used by heller they could just be
alternate forms of the night sword used
by her in the comics and they were
obsidian in nature so
pretty much not so most probably they
just had the same name since it sounded
cool for the makers of the movie thor
ragnarok since they did not have
copyright over using the all black in
the mcu
so anyway i hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do click that like
button for support subscribe and most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till next time take care fam